ae
olá é um prazer enorme estar aqui
convosco não é virtual para mim falar
não é mais um que está aqui está um
microfone e falar um pouco sobre aquilo
que foi o meu percurso desde pequenino
como é que eu fiquei apaixonado por ano
o artur das canções e falar sobre sobre
sobre a aventura que tem sido participar
neste mundo que eu nunca pensei que
realmente é
vamos contar e vocês vão perceber como é
que isso vai acontecendo é esta aventura
desconstruir a paixão pela música eo
percurso do castelo uma fotografia
profissional fez qualquer um de nós tem
um significado para mim é da feira é
bastante importante não sei se daqui
perto daqui então é importante o
contexto de onde vive também para para
as dificuldades que existem prestaram os
autos que é preciso no mundo artístico
mais conhecimento falando existe
dificuldade em todas em todas as
profissões
eu vou avançar para a lei né
sou é o pequenino e com cinco anos pra
ir já já tentar têxtil 9
é nesta altura eu lembro-me caê trouxe
esta cirurgia porque nessa altura eu
lembro via na pré primária e eu lembro
não sabem que eu queria ser perguntavam
na praia pré que eu queria ser eu dizia
que ia ser bombeiro a polícia
os canais de televisão rtp 1 rtp 2
tempos e passou um filme sou eu e os
meus irmãos e eu vou avançar para a paz
ou uma apresentação de um filme ea minha
mãe disse no início da década de 80 é um
filme na televisão se chama de visão em
comum não era só um animado e não é só o
pré primária e não era só um beijo de
influências e etc que o imaginário de
uma criança e então percebi que havia um
mundo o filme a vida é minha música eu
comecei a cantar no idioma que não
existia não é eu tentava cantar ela não
saiu que eu pensava
o inglês mas qualquer levado nem sequer
sabia que vemos havia nada lá época ou
em goiânia e então despertem para a
música
nesta nesta temporada sou eu o senti que
na história que foi como é que eu
comecei a aprender a tocar o primeiro
instrumento aprender a tocar guitarra e
eu estava no futebol só que meu pai não
deixou jogar futebol porque eu não era
assim o aluno em casa de casa aos 13
anos 14
aqui não sei quantos treinos
a roupa e eu estava lá tenha uma seca
tremenda estava lá sentava me perguntou
o que fazer caso seja muito mais lá
tinha feito e é óbvio né tempo porque
aprendi a tocar um instrumento e eu
pensei logo instrumento música eu gosto
de música mas de certeza que não vou
conseguir aprender um instrumento
duvidavam de mim próprio e eu não
poderia aprender um instrumento era giro
mas temos amigos que está em casa até
quem sabe um dia podia ser tipo elvis
presley porque a minha mãe estava muito
alto e eu vejo que ouve ou assiste em
casa e seguiu assim as taxas certeza que
eu não tenho capacidade para tocar viola
nem nem consigo não vai lá tenta não ser
que o tratamento
então eu digo já não têm autoestima
suficiente para pensar que é conseguir
tocar o instrumento sequer
saiba que será uma coisa muito difícil
escalação eu sou muito inteligente
voltado e conseguir é são as
inseguranças que se calhar às vezes
tínhamos antes de nos retirar paulo de
ensino
minha mãe foi quem fez essa força é não
foi tribunal foi jogar futebol para ver
se melhorava as notas né mas de aprender
um instrumento viola e aqui eu não era
assim tão difícil como eu pensava que
era algo carinho só fui aprendendo e
comecei a fazer as primeiras canções e
entretanto nesta altura na escola
secundária sá de miranda da fé é havia
muita gente a começar a aprender a tocar
instrumentos todos todos ninguém a nada
né
a via já havia muitas bandas a começar e
minha primeira banda larga
fizemos primeiro espetáculo alento cheio
de adrenalina de estar a tocar para um
pavilhão cheio da malta do liceu e um
rapaz timinho não estava a cantar se
quer é tocar guitarra guitarra e então
eu fui atropelado pela música lado não
está em cima do palco perceber que é
espetacular um todo não só menor no ano
anterior
é preciso ver se vai falhar se vai ser a
insulina o que aconteceu conosco
uma coisa importante que está sendo a
pensar o caso hoje não pensar muito
nisso mas naquela altura eu nem dormi no
ano anterior em saber como é que vai ser
e será que eu vou me enganar esquece vou
fazer figura do do sul básico eu lembro
uma música da corte atinge am
tentar uma coisa muito básica curto
muito vai ficar apaixonada por música e
eu digo uma coisa não sei se é assim
todos os seus mas nós conhecemos a
primeira feira um monte de bandas
a via só em dois bairros nesta cidade
para tocar não um bar perto do tribunal
e do estado marco em castro e era lá que
as bandas tocavam pois havia também a
cafeteria que surgiu surgiu também
autora do céu mas o café não fazer tanto
hoje em dia quem será que é para os 14
de março
né é então é que eu era espetacular ou
salvar viola pra escola e de repente aí
umas 20 pessoas ou 30 tem algum conserto
né então eu comecei a perceber é país
resulta trazer a viola está pronto pra
cortar o gil e conheci algumas pessoas o
que seu time e tal
e então começamos a fazer umas bandas e
começamos a tocar quando foi assim que a
coisa foi acontecendo pra homem
não é porque os meus pais era fazendo
isso mais ou menos uma banda na altura
do de malta ldu venceu um chamado john
dom a qui a volta mas vamos lá focar
novamente em santa maria da feira
santa maria da feira nunca teve nenhuma
banda ou nenhum artista com sucesso
naquela altura então não havia nenhum
exemplo não havia aqui uma indústria
governá então nós ficamos em baixo e
pouco porque normalmente ninguém queria
ouvir uma banda desconhecida já
conhecidas para cá não cria uma
desconhecida e nós lá e vim por favor e
não pagavam nada que eu era assim e até
tem uma história gira que nesta altura
nós ficamos num bar
é tempo de pôr favor pra tocar no bar em
iowa é e eles deixaram de tocar
oficiamos jantar que era uma criancinha
e nós ficamos umas três músicas
este já na altura já existe fashion e
cada umas três músicas e o fulano o
seguinte vai ter connosco e disse assim
vai me ver lá deixar vocês vão para
tocar porque você estava tão é mandar
embora os clientes todos e eu fiquei
assim só tocar três músicas que acabou e
nós chegamos muito triste na altura
ficámos assim for assim isso mandamos
embora tivéssemos começado a coisa mais
engraçada que passado um ano
vamos lá se vêem os mil pontos o que foi
que enquanto inovar com aquilo tudo e
todos com um
toda a gente famosa e os concursos fator
x
aquelas coisas todas o que eles querem é
famosa
eu nunca quis criar esse caminho eu
podia ter posto uma estrela de cinema
eu não quero ser famoso eu quero é um
dia quem sabe talvez canalho uma vez é
esse meu grande objetivo
e então reunião de mão tanto aquela
malta fim o mesmo objetivo é tentar
furar na alguma coisa tentar não
desistir porque vocês terem uma idéia
está com a namorada
o feirense o outro tá outros
nós estamos a ensaiar também não vai
além dos call to com um musical jovem
saiba se não acontecer nada nós queremos
sair daqui extremos concertos na
concessionária e então para jamal
traficada vamos gravar uma coisa e vamos
ver se stefan foi tipo
depois de tantas bandas já está nos 20
tais e música eu já estou farto isto
acontece na verdade canções ninguém
ouvia assim então ok
o baixista tem o guitarrista tenho a
triste hora lá fazer um projeto e vamos
tentar gravar alguma coisa
e assim foi
a é on avança um estudo rápido né andar
para trás a parlamentar
pronto
então nós gravamos nosso primeiro é p
a música é uma paixão mas atenção
nós começamos por paixão esperamos por
um lado isso não é não é fácil dar uma
assistência
primeiro foi com o produtor que quiser
viagens produziram então não foi o que
ouviu a nossa música através pensa costa
e então eu eo e entrou e nós
nós temos um enorme uma vez na rádio mas
fui visitar o meu curso
mas vamos lá dizer que quando era mais
novo eu comecei também com um não gosta
foi então que o i e ii na altura eu
nunca tive vergonha de mostrar estreia a
minha namorada e ela e as outras pessoas
não vão gostar e eu fiquei assim alta
eu acho que aí olha então deve ser mesmo
boa
é então mostrei o pessoal da banda e o
pessoal da banda já acabou tendo a taxa
avançado é que eu estou a começar
resumindo ela a música da banda e
altamente a música foi um sucesso enorme
campanha da tnl conhecia portugal surgiu
tem uma história para contar a lista
é então a história gira foi contratar a
música estava quase morta do t2
porque mulher cantar em inglês com
button a cantar em português e europeu
que surgiu ninguém queria uma música do
banco em nada porque eu falava sobre uma
casa e e é o único banco que não foi
proposta a música é aquela que vai ter
como primeira música que ele achava a
música podia fazer e então sou eu e tal
e então depois o penta por seu banco
fica na tua música temos três milhões de
euros para investir na canção e eu
fiquei assim do gênero como é que é
possível e tal
a minha música estava morta quando
narrada em turmas até por seu lado
também deu um salto enorme
meu projeto é só porque depois o meu
caminhão
o caminhão foi usado um caminhão eu
tinha que andar de cima do caminhão do
eu tinha tipo equilibra a gente não foi
treinado por cima do caminhão pois tá
solto cacciola conseguiu fazer isso foi
para cima do caminhão depois daquilo
andava né
só o senhor do caminho acho que a minha
beleza 54 liga ninguém que eu fico mal
o caminhão e um serviço de cortiça paulo
sérgio e embraiagem pifou e eu fiquei
assim do gênero então pra cima e eu nem
segurar em um tripé com os prés
microfone e falar não caía e tudo e
então eu amo não havia nada tipo no
ônibus segurar aquilo começou a nada
porque achei que ia da ponte luís i é o
cope transpor semana para o trânsito
will assim é pá mas gastar três milhões
de euros misto e os calhar vamos
equilibrar o caminhão bloqueia o rio
fitzroy isto vai vai ser no final da
minha vida da minha carreira e minha
primeira com estilo é mais ou menos a 51
dólares 60 tubo eu saí mas depois da
frente do microfone e começa a filmar
não sei que é assim
depois de apanhar durante a hora que
aquilo é é que eu era acima da pontuação
do vento
e você pensa eu comecei a região mas
também da pupunha pernas impediu trace
quando a gente outra mudança mas
conseguiu sobreviver
essa fase à tarde depois foi bastante
mais fácil foi não foi foi na onda mais
fácil e foi o dia mais quente do ano
fiquei desidratado só começou só
consegui começou quando lisa a seguir
mas foi fantástico irá estimular as
notícias do gaúcho viu mesmo pequenos e
dores
depois estas revistas no tipo que não
custava nada a fazer porque eu moro
vendedores que não há risco no mundo da
rádio comercial também foi foi no
castelo fiz foi um dos contemplados e
então fizeram biografia a apresentação
de alguns dos músicos
as primeiras partes 2009
concertos acho que é uma falha fez a
apresentação do último disco foi quem
não gostou é compor também da área
comercial e funk foi para três
instituições
as receitas do clube puma não quer
encontrar uma idéia é dar autógrafos
o povo também muito próxima do palco
estou agora foi um estúdio em glasgow
onde esteve a gravar agora as minhas
últimas canções
falta só que já gravou com 15 mais com
os genes são a minha é que o ano seja na
música é outra coisa qualquer
nós temos que focar e e esse nós fomos
atrás das coisas que as coisas não vêm
ter connosco é possível chegar a bom
porto
acho que o principal obstáculo para
todos somos sempre nós quando os
obstáculos para tudo
é isso
brinca